la théorie du big bang est un des grands
monuments de la physique moderne est
aujourd'hui plus aucun cosmologie ce ne
remet en cause ses fondements et
pourtant comme pour toutes théories
scientifiques nouvelles les débuts n'ont
pas été si simple si elle a été imaginée
à la fin des années 1920 la théorie du
big bang a été initialement assez
controversé et critiqué et ce n'est qu'à
partir des années 60 qu'elle s'est
imposé comme étant la meilleure théorie
pour décrire le passé et les origines de
l'univers et tout ça grâce à une
découverte qui fut un argument
extrêmement puissant en faveur de la
théorie du big bang le rayonnement
cosmologique
[Musique]
je vais pas vous faire un épisode sur
les détails de la théorie du big bang
ça sera pour une autre fois mais
l'essentiel à savoir c'est qu'on vit
dans un univers qui est en expansion
c'est à dire que la plupart des galaxies
s'éloignent les unes des autres à partir
de l'observation du mouvement des
galaxies et grâce aux équations de la
cosmologie
il est possible de rembobiner le film de
l'histoire de l'univers et ses calculs
nous montre que plus on remonte dans le
temps plus l'univers était dense et
chaud et d'après les équations il y à 13
milliards d'années l'univers et est même
tellement dense et tellement chaud que
toute la physique que l'on connaît il
était bouleversé dans les années 40
alors que la théorie du big bang et est
loin de faire l'unanimité parmi les
scientifiques des physiciens sont dit
que si l'univers avait été effectivement
si chaud dans le passé il devait bien
rester des traces quelque part une sorte
de vestiges notamment il faut savoir que
si ce scénario est correct là matière à
l'époque des premiers instants du big
bang n'était pas dans l'état qu'on lui
connaît actuellement ont déjà y avait
que deux éléments de l'hydrogène est un
peu d'hélium
mais surtout les atomes n'existait pas
en tant que tel prenons l'exemple de
l'atome d'hydrogène normalement il est
constitué d'un proton et d'un électron
qui lui est liée par la forces
électrostatiques
mais cette association n'est possible
que s'il ne fait pas trop chaud on sait
qu'au dessus d'une certaine température
à peu près 3000 degrés l'électron peut
se retrouver arraché du proton et donc à
l'époque des premiers instants du big
bang on avait bien des électrons et des
protons mais la température était
tellement élevés qu'ils étaient
dissocier les uns des autres pour former
ce qu'on appelle un plasma un plasma
très chaud une chose que vous savez sans
doute c'est que quand de la matière est
chaude
elle émet des rayonnements c'est ce qui
fait qu'une ampoule à incandescence bris
ou que des braises rougeoie et le
rayonnement émis va dépendre de la
température ça se voit très bien avec de
l'acier qu'on forge au fur et à mesure
contre chauffe il rougeoie et plus sa
température augmente plus il devient
orange jaune et enfin blanc à
température ambiante
aussi tous les objets maîtres de la
lumière mais dans les infrarouges et il
faut par exemple une caméra thermique
pour s'en rendre compte
tous ces rayonnements liée à la
température on les appelle rayonnement
de corps noir
oui même si la matière chauffer n'est
justement pas noir et bien à l'époque
des premiers instants du big bang
notre plasma primordial très chaud et
mettait lui aussi un rayonnement de
corps noir
sauf que quand la lumière se balade dans
un plasma elle ne peut pas vraiment le
traverser parce qu'elle interagit très
fortement avec les particules chargées
les protons les électrons et donc les
faux
ton qui composent le rayonnement de
corps noir sont en permanence absorber
et diffusé dans le plasma puisque les
ondes lumineuses ne pouvait pas
traverser le plasma ont dit qu'à
l'époque la matière était opaque mais au
bout d'un moment il s'est passé un truc
au fur et à mesure que l'univers s'étend
des la densité est donc la température
ont diminué et dont celle ci est passé
sous le seuil d'à-peu-près 3000 degrés
les électrons ont commencé à pouvoir
s'associer aux protons pour former des
vrais atom et les atomes e
n'interagissent quasiment pas avec les
photons qui composent la lumière c'est à
dire que quand le plasma s'est
transformé en atom et ben soudainement
la matière est devenue transparente les
photons se sont donc mis à voyager
librement et à vivre leur vie
indépendamment de celle des atomes
on appelle ce moment le découplage et on
peut estimer quand il a eu lieu 380
mille ans après l'hypothétique naissance
de l'univers et ce rayonnement qui a été
soudainement libéré au moment du
découplage
eh ben il devrait toujours être là en
principe l'univers devrait être baignée
d'une sorte de lumière qu'on appelle
parfois le rayonnement fossile
parce qu'il s'agit d'un vestige de ses
premières époques de l'histoire de
l'univers
[Musique]
alors à quoi il peut bien ressembler ce
rayonnement je vous ai dit qu'il a été
émis à l'époque du découplage qu'en la
matière était à environ 3000 degrés 3000
degrés c'est à peu près la température
du filament d'une ampoule à
incandescence donc cette lumière fossile
du big bang elle devrait être à peu près
du même genre à une sorte de jaune clair
sauf que quand je regarde dehors la nuit
je vois pas une radiation jaune clair
qui gagnerait tout le ciel la raison
c'est qu'il ya un élément supplémentaire
à prendre en compte c'est l'expansion de
l'univers
on l'a dit l'expansion de l'univers tend
à éloigner tous les objets les uns des
autres et notamment à augmenter les
distances entre les galaxies et bien sûr
cette lumière qui baigne l'univers
depuis tout ce temps elle a aussi un
effet elle allonge les longueurs d'onde
et donc elles changent la couleur du
rayonnement
entre le moment du découplage est
aujourd'hui on estime que l'univers
s'est dilaté d'un facteur environ 1000
et donc le rayonnement qui a été émis à
l'époque il ressemble plus du tout à
celui d'un corps à 3000 degrés mais
plutôt à celui d'un corps à 3 kelvin
c'est à dire 3 degrés au dessus du zéro
absolu -273 degrés celsius la lumière
émise par un corps aussi froid ça n'est
plus de la lumière visible comme pour
une lampe ni même des infrarouges comme
pour les corps et les objets qui nous
entourent
sur cette figure vous voyez les spectres
c'est à dire la composition en longueur
d'onde de la lumière émise par des corps
à ces différentes températures pour le
soleil dont la surface est à environ six
mille degrés c de la lumière visible et
des infrarouges pour une lampe à
incandescence à 3000 degrés eh ben c'est
pareil avec + infrarouge pour un objet à
température ambiante 20° c uniquement
des infrarouges et pour un corps à 3
kelvin moins 270 degrés celsius
il s'agit principalement de rayonnement
dix micro-ondes micro-ondes c'est une
appellation conventionnel qui veut dire
que la longueur d'onde et en gros entre
20 mm et 1 m dans le cas du rayonnement
cosmologique le maximum et autour de 1 à
2 mm petite parenthèse pourquoi est-ce
qu'un four micro-ondes s'appelle un four
micro-ondes et ben c'est parce qu'ils
chauffent au moyen de rayonnement dont
la longueur d'onde est d'une dizaine de
centimètres
bref si on en croit cette théorie
l'univers devrait être baignée d'un
rayonnement micro-onde qui serait une
sorte de restes de fossiles de cette
époque du découplage je vous raconte
tout ça comme si c'était évident mais ce
raisonnement que je viens de vous
décrire c'est seulement la fin des
années 40 que des physiciens comme
alpher gamma et hermann ont commencé à
le faire et ils ont essayé de calculer
la température correspondante
il faut savoir que c'était une époque où
là
théorie du big bang était en compétition
avec d'autres approches entre 1948 et
1964 plusieurs estimations de la
température du rayonnement cosmologique
ont été faites
elle se balader en gros entre 3 et 20
kelvin et en 1964 robert dit que qui
était à l'époque à princeton décida de
se lancer dans la construction d'un
appareil de mesure pour essayer de
détecter ce fameux rayonnement
cosmologique
au même moment en mai 1964 pas très loin
de là dans le new-jersey 2
radioastronomes penzias et wilson
essayer de régler leurs nouvelles
antennes super sensible
cette antenne elle avait été construite
par les bell labs et laboratoires de
recherche de la compagnie de télécoms et
yên tu y es son but était d'étudier des
communications par rayonnement
micro-onde entre la terre et des sortes
de ballons satellite
rien à voir avec de la cosmologie donc
mais ces deux radioastronomes penzias et
wilson
quand ils essayaient de régler leurs
antennes il était en permanence gêné par
une espèce de bruit de fond vous savez
un peu comme quand on a un bruit de
friture sur un autoradio
alors ils ont tenté d'éliminer toutes
les sources d'interférences possible et
notamment ils se sont tapés un
fastidieux nettoyage de crottes de
pigeons dans l'antenne mais rien n'ya
fait impossible de se débarrasser du
bruit un bruit étrangement similaire un
rayonnement à 3 kelvin alors penzias et
wilson n'était pas des cosmologistes 1
et donc qu'il connaissait pas cette
théorie du rayonnement fossile mais au
bout d'un moment par bouche à oreille il
finira par entendre parler des travaux
de robert tu dis que à princeton et tous
les trois sont réunis et ils ont réalisé
que ce que penzias et wilson venait de
découvrir
c'était ce fameux rayonnement que robert
dit que avait calculé et essayer lui
vainement de détecter ils ont alors
décidé de publier conjointement deux
articles relatant à la fois la
découverte par penzias et wilson et
l'explication théorique par dit que et
voilà on venait de mettre à jour ce
fameux rayonnement cosmologique
ce vestige du passé chou et danses de
l'univers qui apportait une preuve
décisive à la théorie du big bang
pour cette découverte qui restait malgré
tout accidentelle benzia si wilson reçu
le prix nobel en 1978 mais rien pour dit
que alpher gamme off et tous les autres
qui avait quand même réussi l'exploit de
prédire le truc avant qu'on le découvre
autant dire que les physiciens
théoriciens avait bien les boules
heureusement 34 ans plus tard ils ont
été vengé pour le boson de higgs il
s'est passé exactement l'inversé le
nobel est allé aux théoriciens et rien
pour ceux qui avaient fait des
expériences au cern un peu vache quand
même
[Musique]
mais revenons à ce fameux rayonnement
qu'est ce qu'on peut en dire bien suite
à la découverte de pédiatrie wilson
plusieurs expériences ont été lancés
pour essayer de mieux le mesurer et le
caractérise et après quelques détection
menées depuis le sol
on décida finalement de lancer un
satellite pour aller le mesurer
directement depuis l'espace le satellite
kobe pour cosmic background explorer il
faut savoir que ces mesures sont quand
même beaucoup plus facile à faire depuis
l'espace déjà ça permet de s'affranchir
d'un certain nombre de perturbations
mais surtout comme le satellite tourne
autour de la terre
eh bien ça permet de mesurer le
rayonnement qui provient de toutes les
directions du ciel
kobe fut lancé en 1989 et ses premières
mesures furent publiés au début des
années 90 tout d'abord elle confirmèrent
que le rayonnement cosmologique était
bien un rayonnement de corps noir et
même le meilleur corps noir du monde
il faut savoir qu'un objet chauffer une
certaine température on m ait jamais
exactement un rayonnement de corps noir
qui colle parfaitement à la théorie mais
dans le cas du rayonnement fossile
l'accord est parfait ensuite kobe a
permis de préciser la température du
rayonnement pas tout à fait trois kelvin
mais 2,725 kelvin c'est précis et en
le satellite a révélé une information
encore plus cruciale la température du
rayonnement fossile n'est pas exactement
la même suivant la direction du ciel
dans laquelle on regarde elle varie en
gros entre 2,525 et 2 726 kelvin c'est
vraiment pas grand chose c'est des
variations qui sont même pas un millième
degré et pourtant on va voir que c'est
capital
ces variations c'est ce qu'on appelle
les anisotropies du rayonnement
cosmologique et on leur présente avec
des cartes de ce genre cette carte c'est
une carte du ciel
vous savez de même qu'on peut
représenter la sphère terrestre sous
forme d'un planisphère
eh ben on fait la même chose avec la
sphère céleste cette ellipse représente
le ciel au dessus de nos têtes
chaque mois sur cette carte est une
direction du ciel et on symbolise avec
un code couleur les variations de
température du rayonnement cosmologique
par rapport à la moyenne
le rouge correspond à une direction du
ciel de laquelle nous parvient un
rayonnement légèrement plus chaud et
bleu légèrement plus froid suite à la
mission comme et d'autres satellites sur
lancers pour essayer d'améliorer la
précision de ces mesures dans les autres
pays il y eut d'abord la mission de blum
ap
entre 2001 et 2010 et puis la mission
européenne planque qui s'est achevée en
2013 mais dont je crois on n'a pas fini
d'exploiter tous les résultats ce que
vous voyez ici ce sont des cartes danese
autres opi de plus en plus précises qui
ont été obtenues comme une fois
on aurait prises avec une meilleure
résolution et bien le révèle de plus en
plus de détails
elles nous apprennent plein de choses
sur les origines de l'univers si vous
pouviez vous balader et voir le
rayonnement micro-onde avec vos yeux
voilà à peu près ce que vous verrez
[Musique]
il faut savoir que c'est à nous autres
pays ne sont pas quelconque et qu'elles
sont prévues par la théorie du big bang
on va voir comment les analyses
commençons par un cas plus simple
imaginez une route avec des bosses qui
sont comme des fluctuations de sa
hauteur on peut analyser l'intensité de
ces fluctuations elles peuvent être plus
ou moins forte mais aussi leur longueur
d'onde c'est à dire la longueur qui
sépare deux pics
est-ce que c'est tous les mettre tous
les 10 cm on peut aussi avoir des
fluctuations qui sont un mélange de
plusieurs longueurs d'onde comme ici
alors pour caractériser ça on calcule
l'intensité des fluctuations en fonction
de leur longueur d'onde pour un mélange
de fluctuation à un mètre et à 10 cm et
ben ça va ressembler à ça alors pour
ceux qui connaissent techniquement on
fait une transformée de fourier comme
quand on analyse les fréquences d'un son
revenons à la carte de température du
rayonnement cosmologique
dans ce cas là les fluctuations sont pas
séparés par une certaine longueur d'onde
comme sur une route mais par un certain
angle dans le ciel eh ben on peut quand
même faire le même genre d' analyse
imaginé quelque chose qui fluctuent sur
un cercle
mais les fluctuations se produisent avec
une certaine taille angulaire ici
environ 60 degrés ce sont des
fluctuations de grande échelle et la 5°
donc à plus petite échelle et bien sûr
on peut avoir un mélange des deux et on
peut faire le même genre de
représentations l'intensité des
fluctuations en fonction de leur taille
angulaire si je vous embête avec tous
ces préliminaires un peu technique c'est
parce que si on fait ce genre d' analyse
avec les fluctuations de température du
rayonnement cosmologique on obtient une
courbe qui est à mon sens une des plus
belles et des plus importantes de toute
la physique fondamentale moderne c'est
le spectre des fluctuations du
rayonnement cosmologique
alors comment on lit cette courbe mais
elle représente l'intensité des
fluctuations en fonction de la taille
angulaire ici vous voyez un gros pic à
environ 1 degré ça veut dire qu'il ya
des fluctuations importantes à des
tailles angulaire de 1° et ça correspond
à tous ces petits grumeaux que vous
voyez ici qu'ils font en gros un 360e de
la largeur de l'image d'un grumeaux à
son voisin la température a tendance à
pas mal fluctuer et c'est ce que ce pic
reflète les pics supérieurs
correspondent à des grumeaux qui sont
plus fins et qu'on distingue plus
difficilement sur l'image mais qui
montre qu'on a d'autres fluctuation à
des échelles angulaire encore plus
petite
alors pourquoi cette courbe est
importante et bien parce qu'elle colle
parfaitement à la théorie du big bang et
qu'elle nous apprend une foule de choses
sur notre univers et sa composition
ici vous voyez donc la courbe que l'on
me
par exemple avec les données de la
mission planck si l'univers avait une
densité de matière et d'énergie 20 %
plus élevée que ce qu'elle est la courbe
serait différente elle ressemblerait à
ça inversement avec 20% en moins la
courbe serait comme ça vous voyez donc
que l'alluré la position des pics nous
renseigne sur la quantité de matières
contenues dans l'univers mais aussi sur
sa nature si l'univers ne contenait ni
matière noire ni énergie noire que de la
matière ordinaire et bien la courbe ce
serait comme ça et avec de la matière
noire mais pas d'énergie noire elle
serait comme ça en utilisant des modèles
et en cherchant les paramètres qui
permettent de reproduire exactement la
courbe que l'on observe on peut
déterminer avec précision la composition
de l'univers en masse et en énergie
environ 5 % de matière ordinaire 26 % de
matière noire et 69 % d'énergie noire
cette courbe c'est comme un livre dans
lequel on peut lire les grands
paramètres cosmologiques de la théorie
du big bang
c'est pas beau ça alors on entend
parfois des gens qui essayent de réfuter
l'idée de big bang en proposant des
explications alternatives notamment à
l'expansion des galaxies mais c'est
oublier que la meilleure preuve
expérimentale de la théorie du big bang
c'est cette courbe incroyablement
précise et pour essayer de trouver une
théorie alternative qui reproduisent
cette courbe et ben vous pouvez vous
lever tôt
aujourd'hui on n'a pas fini d'explorer
tous les mystères du rayonnement
cosmologique
il ya notamment un autre type de
fluctuation à part les fluctuations de
températures qui sont les fluctuations
de polarisation et on estime qu'elles
pourraient nous apprendre pas mal de
choses sur une lointaine époque
primordial de l'univers ce qu'on appelle
l'inflation
il ya quelques années il y avait eu des
annonces un peu prématuré à ce sujet et
en fait on attend toujours de confirmer
ce qu'on appelle les ondes
gravitationnelles primordial qu'ils sont
des ondes gravitationnelles comme celle
dont on a parlé récemment mais qui se
serait produite au moment de l'inflation
et qui aurait laissé comme une empreinte
dans la polarisation du rayonnement
cosmologique enfin n'ont jusqu'ici on
l'a quand même toujours pas
officiellement détectée autre mystère la
carte actuelle du rayonnement
cosmologique fait apparaître une région
bizarre le point froid qui pourrait
correspondre à une région anormalement
vide de l'univers qu'on appelle parfois
le super vide enfin dernier aspect on
pense qu'on mesure en plus précisément
les fluctuations aux grandes échelles
angulaire qui aujourd'hui ont des bars
des rats à ces grosses on pourra
apprendre plein de choses sur des
phénomènes de gravité quantique qui se
seraient produits aux tout premiers
instants l'univers notamment dans la
théorie de la gravité quand
la boucle dont j'avais parlé dans un
épisode précédent à bail acheter car et
aurélien barrau ont montré que la
cosmologie quantique à boucles prédit
des déviations dans les fluctuations par
rapport au scénario classique mais avec
les données actuelles les erreurs de
mesure sont encore trop grandes pour
faire la distinction
à ce jour plusieurs nouvelles missions
sont à l'étude
et elle devrait permettre de mesurer
avec encore plus de précision ce
rayonnement cosmologique et on finira
peut-être donc à jour par avoir la
réponse à toutes ces questions
merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo comme d'hab
n'hésitez pas à partager laïque et vous
abonner la cloche tout ça si ça vous
intéresse vous pouvez aller jeter un
oeil à mon deuxième livre qui vient de
sortir et qui s'appelle insoluble mais
vrai si vous voulez des news de la
chaînes vous pouvez retrouver sur
facebook et sur twitter
et ceux qui le souhaitent peuvent de
soutenir sur petit ping merci à bientôt
[Musique]